[Music]
the sentence starred of Cameron has cast
more than one love spell on her co-stars
she's made it clear that she's attracted
to both her male and female celebrity
friends so let's find out who Dov is
rescued with true love's kiss stay tuned
to the end to find out if the rumors
about Dov and Thomas Doherty breaking up
are true if you're new here hit that
notification bell to stay up to date on
our latest videos and click the thumbs
up button if you want more of these
videos now here are five guys and girls
dove Cameron has dated Ryan McCartan
Ryan McCartan and dove Cameron met on
the set of Liv and Maddie as the
on-screen couple Maddie and diggie but
fans must have sensed their chemistry
because they fell for the couple in real
life as hard as the two lovebirds fell
for each other they even had a band
together called the girl and the
dreamcatcher
they looked very happy in press photos
but dog was only 17 years old when they
got together so when their relationship
took off like a rocket and they got
engaged in 2016
everyone's heads were spinning only six
months after announcing their engagement
the couple called it quits
apparently dove with the one to call it
off Ryan posted on Twitter that Doug
decided this relationship isn't what she
wants he said they still love each other
very much and asked fans to please be
sensitive as it was painful for him dov
also tweeted about the break-up saying
she thanked all her fans for their
support and full hearts in this very
intense and human time she shared that
there was a lot of love between her and
Ryan fans were sad about the break-up at
first but later commented that dove
looked much happier post breakup Kiersey
Clemons there have been rumors that dove
has a love for girls as well as guys
those rumors seemed totally valid after
dove took tit snapchat to post a video
of her kissing Kiersey Clemons Piercy is
the up-and-coming actress from the 2015
film dope she is set to star in the
upcoming film about the flash Clemons
recently played the role of an LGBTQ
character on the anthology series hearts
beat loud when asked about whether she
thought she was normalizing the LGBTQ
experience she responded saying she
didn't think they were normalizing it
but that it is normal she said her
character isn't a creature that you have
to make appear normal
she said it's not a hobbit or a wizard
well she certainly did not look like a
hobbit in that video when she was
kissing Doug Cameron when Dov was asked
if she was bi or just sharing a lovely
moment with her BFF she tweeted that she
loves girls / women so much she wrote
like wow so much appreciation for her
own gender she seemed to be egging on
her fans because she continued telling
the boys to watch out because she's
gonna steal their girl Garret Clayton in
December 2016 dove Cameron and Garrett
Clayton were caught smooching off-camera
while on the set of hairspray Live Love
was playing the role of amber opposite
to Garrett sleek some fans thought maybe
they were just rehearsing were they
really dating or just practicing for the
cameras fans were quick to point out
that they posted a lot of cute Instagram
pics and videos together in one of those
posts stuff called Garrett her favorite
human and Garrett posted an IG pic
giving them the couple named da vet and
said they practiced their selfie game
whenever they want to to be totally fair
it was never officially announced that
the two were dating it's totally
possible that they're just close friends
who were getting into character for the
show you gotta admit they were totally
compatible on-screen but maybe Dov has a
natural ability to connect with her
co-stars because she's a genuinely kind
person with a giving heart
Garrett certainly seems to be a big fan
our belief is that they were friends do
you guys think they were romantically
linked or were the fans just eagerly
speculating Bella Thorne the actress
singer and fellow Disney star Bella
Thorne came out as bi in the most
low-key way ever in 2016 one of her
Twitter fans asked her if she was bi she
responded with a simple yes then there
were pictures floating around of Bella
kissing her brother's ex-girlfriend
after Bella broke up with her boyfriend
then the rumors started about Dov and
Bella since dove hinted at her love of
her own gender fans were shipping Bella
and dove pretty hard one fan by the name
of lucia tweeted asking dove and bella
outright if they were going to hook up
lucia added that she thought they would
both be goals bella responded saying
that she definitely thought about it
with some flirty emojis dove tweeted
that she thought the two would look
pretty cute together and posted it with
the hashtag power couple that sparked a
lot of excitement among fan
dov must have had second thoughts
because apparently she deleted the
tweets she posted and replaced it with
the tweet hashtag power couple so
cryptic so did the shake it up actress
and The Descendants bad girl hook up or
was it all just for show they seemed
pretty cozy in this picture what do you
guys think
Thomas Doherty if you've been hiding
under a rock for the last year then you
probably don't know about the intensely
romantic relationship between dove
Cameron and her descendants to co-star
Thomas Doherty the two have been sending
strong love vibes for the past year they
post about their happy relationship all
the time on social media Thomas even has
a jacket with a picture of doves face on
the back which was made by a fan dove
says it's his favorite jacket he wore it
when the couple went to Coachella this
year they also went on a romantic
getaway to Paris to celebrate their
one-year anniversary
they look so blissfully in love dove
recently shared that Thomas moved to Los
Angeles to live with her but there were
rumors recently that they were breaking
up doves shut that rumor down hard and
fast when she posted on Twitter with the
public service announcement that she and
Thomas are fine she wrote no they are
not broken up yes they are still
together no they are not fighting she
said they're madly in love and better
than ever
then she told fans - please stop
speculating / spreading rumors when
there is no basis at all for them so
there you have it fans all's well and
those were the five guys and girls that
dove Cameron is dated thanks for
watching the things catch you later
[Music]